- [Voiceover] Given the
cost of a hardcover book,
the price of it typically
hovers around $25,
many consumers ask their book dealers,
"When will the paperback be out?"
So let's just think about this.
Given the cost of a hardcover book.
So this is what we're talking about.
We're talking about the
cost of a hardcover book.
The price of it typically
hovers around $25.
So they're trying to give us
a little bit more information
on the cost of a hardcover book.
But this clause here that they give us,
the price of it typically
hovers around $25,
is very wordy, and it's very clumsy.
What they're really saying,
given the cost of a hardcover book,
which typically hovers around $25.
So I'm going to look for
a phrase that's closer to
which typically hovers around $25.
So let's look at our choices.
So the first choice is always
exactly as they wrote it here.
So I'm going to rule that one out,
because it really does feel
very wordy and very clumsy.
Given the cost of a hardcover book,
and typically it hovers
at a price around $25.
Well once again, this is a
little bit strangely worded.
And typically it hovers.
We really want to have a
relative pronoun, which, here.
We're talking about the
cost, which does something.
Which hovers around $25.
So choice C actually seems
to do the trick for us.
Given the cost of a hardcover book, which,
and what is the relative
pronoun which referring to?
It's referring to the
cost of a hardcover book,
which typically hovers around $25,
many consumers ask their book dealers,
"When will the paperback be out?"
Well, this one feels really good.
It conveys the exact meaning that we want.
It's much shorter.
Which typically hovers
is much shorter than
the price of it typically hovers,
and it's a lot less convoluted.
So C is definitely where I'd like to go.
Now let's just look at the other choices.
In that it typically hovers.
Given the cost of a hardcover book,
in that it typically hovers.
Well once again, you're
just really meaning to say
which typically hovers.
In that, you're doing
this prepositional phrase.
It's a very strange thing.
Just to kind of give a little bit
of an extra context of the cost.
So I'm going to rule that one out.
They typically hover.
So this one, they, you're talking about
something in the plural,
and the cost is singular.
The cost of a hardcover book,
at least the way it's being referred to.
So we're not saying they.
This is plural, while
the relative pronoun,
or in this case, just the pronoun,
is referring to is singular, the cost.
Singular.
So that's why this one right over here
doesn't make any sense.
So, yeah.
Given the cost of a hardcover book,
which typically hovers around $25,
many consumers ask their book dealers,
"When will the paperback be out?"
That feels very good.